if you do these steps you will get your
first five customers so the first step
to getting this going is you need to get
a list but I don't have a list Alex
you're damn straight you do I want you
to go to your email account to pull all
the contacts that you have in there
anybody that you've ever messaged or
emailed that becomes list one list two
is I want you to go to every single
social media profile that you have go to
your social media profiles where you can
direct message people so if you have
followers that you can DM I want you to
write down every single one of those
people list number three pull out your
phone look for your contacts I want you
to export them list one is all your
email contacts list two is all of your
Social contacts and list three is all of
your phone and private personal contacts
if you add all three of those together
you will have a shitload more leads than
you thought you did